c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur France 24 à la
une ce soir cette image de Moussa Dadis
Camara sur le banc des accusés l'ex
dictateur guinéen a paru devant le
tribunal de Conakry avec une dizaine de
co-accusés il doit répondre du massacre
du stade du 28 septembre 2009 le procès
a été renvoyé au 4 octobre nous serons
avec notre envoyé spécial à Conakry dans
ce journal
les mesures prises par le Kenya après
l'apparition de plusieurs cas d'Ebola en
Ouganda le pays veut éviter la
propagation de ce virus très contagieux
des contrôles au poste frontières sont
effectués sur tous les voyageurs en
provenance d'Ouganda les détails à
suivre
et puis en cette fin de semaine nous
nous intéresserons aux difficultés
rencontrées par certains écoliers sur le
continent guerre réchauffement
climatique manque de moyens ils sont
nombreux à être déscolarisés ce soir
nous irons au Cameroun coup de
projecteur sur des écoliers des zones
anglophones ayant fui le conflit
reportage à suivre
l'ouverture a été retardée mais le
procès s'est bien tenu ce mercredi sur
le banc des accusés le capitaine Moussa
Dadis Camara l'ancien dictateur guinéen
comparaissait devant un tribunal à
Conakry avec une dizaine de co-accusés
pour le massacre du stade commis le 28
septembre 2009 le compte rendu de notre
envoyé spécial et limendao
les principaux accusés des événements du
28 septembre dans le colonel à Moussa
daliz Camara et les autres accusés ont
fait face au juge en début d'après-midi
dans le tout nouveau un palais de
justice de Conakry construit pour
l'occasion rempli de victimes et de
famille de victimes présentes dès les
premières heures de la journée ils ont
pu assister à la cérémonie de lancement
de ce procès inédit avec la présence du
de l'envoyer spécial du Secrétaire
général des Nations unies mais également
à des procureur de la Cour pénal
internationale et le ministre de la
Justice de la Guinée je vous propose de
l'écouter
mon département je veux dire le
département de la Justice est prêt pour
agir et impression relax pour la
manifestation de la vérité dans le
dossier du 28 septembre et dans les
autres cas de crimes et violation des
droits de l'homme pour les victimes des
événements de 28 septembre ce jour est
très important il l'attendent depuis 13
ans on a pu parler à l'une d'entre elles
je vous propose de l'écouter ceux qui
sont morts nous voulons que c'est si là
ne sont pas morts dans le vide
ils sont morts pour le pays
c'est le pays avant tout et après ça
nous voulons unions on se donne la main
et la paix se règne dans notre pays le
procès retransmit en direct sur la RTG à
la télévision nationale le Guinée à qui
nous avons parlé espère que la vérité
puis on fera et que les victimes
obtiendront réparation
et puis j'ajoute qu'après plus de 2h
d'audience le procès a été renvoyé aux 4
octobre prochain et nous sommes en
direct avec Maître drissat Traoré avocat
de la partie civile secrétaire général
de la FIDH bonsoir Monsieur merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation tout
d'abord quelle est votre sentiment
aujourd'hui à l'ouverture du procès 13
ans après les faits
bonsoir madame aujourd'hui c'est un jour
de soulagement pour nous parce que les
victimes attendent à ce moment depuis 13
ans au moment où nous parlions à la FIDH
à l'eghp à la vie par de ce procès
beaucoup étaient sceptique aujourd'hui
enfin l'audience s'est ouverte c'est
avec soulagement que nous avons
accueilli cela aujourd'hui les victimes
peuvent penser à ce que j'utilise soit
faite pour elle alors Moussa Dadis
Camara a été incarcéré hier il va
présenter aujourd'hui devant les juges
il dit être là pour se laver de ses
accusations qu'attendez-vous de votre
côté de sa comparution
nous entendons que la vérité soit dite
nous en tant qu'avocat de partie civile
nous allons veiller à ce que les
questions et toutes les questions sont
posées pour que chacun des accusés qui
comparaissent dit la vérité nous pensons
qu'aujourd'hui la Guinée et la victime
ont besoin de vérité pour être soulagé
et donc nous attendons que ce process se
déroule selon les règles d'un poussin
juste et équitable avec le respect de
droit des droits de toutes les parties
mais surtout que la vérité soit dite et
nous allons veiller à cela alors le
ministre de la Justice on l'a entendu a
pris la parole aujourd'hui il promet une
indemnisation victime on imagine que
cette question est déjà sur la table
oui nous avons entendu et le ministre
également a indiqué que à ce stade il y
a eu deux fonds au profit des victimes
qui a été créée l'un des fonds consacrés
à l'organisation de ce procès et l'autre
à la réparation mais pour l'heure nous
n'avons pas d'information sur le contenu
l'ampleur de ce fond là et sur les
mécanismes d'accès et comment cela cela
gérer et dont nous attendant pouvoir
comment tout cela tout cela sera mis en
place mais déjà nous allons cette
initiative du gouvernement de transition
nous espérons que cela pourra aller
jusqu'au bout pour que enfin les
victimes soient réparées pour une fois
en Guinée que la justice sera faite pour
une fois enfin que les victimes de la
Guinée des événements en Guinée seront
reconnus entre guinéenne
ne craignez-vous pas que ce procès ne
soit récupéré par le nouveau pouvoir en
Guinée il se tient dans un contexte très
tendu dans le pays
et je vous rappelle que depuis 2017
l'instruction était achevée et jusqu'à
jusqu'à présent sous le régime de
président Alpha Condé l'audience le
procès ne sait jamais ouvert aujourd'hui
nous sommes soulagés que cela soit
ouvert pour nous c'est l'indépendance de
la justice la manière dont ce procès
sera mené qui est important nous ne
regardons pas le moment où le régime qui
est en place pour nous les pour nous et
pour les victimes c'est ce qui sera dit
la manière dont les débats seront
conduits et la manière dont le droit
sera dit c'est ce qui est important
c'est ce que nous retenons merci
beaucoup maître Drissa Traoré avocat de
la partie civile secrétaire général de
la fidr FIDH merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et merci également à Malik
Diakité d'avoir réalisé ce duplex pour
nous
alerte maximale au Kenya après une
multiplication de cas d'Ebola en Ouganda
on nous Ganda voisin pardon le pays a
décidé d'imposer des contrôles à tous
ceux qui franchissent la frontière en
provenance d'Ouganda Luanda qui
enregistre au moins 5 morts de la
maladie Laurent Berthet
des mesures sanitaires renforcées pour
empêcher une nouvelle épidémie d'Ebola
au poste frontières de boussia au Kenya
tous les voyageurs font désormais
l'objet d'un scan de température alors
que le virus continue de se propager en
nous gant d'un voisin
passe par un scanner qui prend leur
température parce que nous savons que la
fièvre est l'un des premiers symptômes
d'Ebola
depuis une semaine l'Ouganda fait face à
une flambée d'Ebola dans le district de
mubendé les autorités sanitaires y ont
déjà recensé 36 cas probables ou
confirmés ainsi que 5 décès liées au
virus et une vingtaine d'autres morts
suspectes une contagion rapide qui se
limite actuellement au centre de
l'Ouganda mais qui suscite des
inquiétudes au Keny Abou sia de nombreux
habitants demandent aux autorités de
multiplier les mesures de détection et
de suivi afin d'empêcher le virus de
traverser la frontière
il y a énormément de gens qui passent
par ici je supplie le gouvernement de
mettre en place des mesures strictes
s'ils ne prennent pas la situation au
sérieux nous allons tous en souffrir
une fille hémorragique hautement
contagieuse le virus Ébola a tué plus de
11000 personnes entre 2013 et 2016 lors
du pic de l'épidémie en Afrique de
l'Ouest et si aucun vaccin n'existe pour
lutter contre le variant dit soudanais
qui s'est vite actuellement en Ouganda
l'OMS assure que l'épidémie peut être
endigué par des mesures de prévention de
traçage et d'isolement
l'actualité en bref et en images le coup
d'envoi officiel de la campagne
présidentielle au Nigeria le leader de
l'opposition à athikou Aboubakar s'est
lancé dans la course mercredi il a
appelé les électeurs à voter massivement
pour lui pour sauver le pays je cite
d'un terrible basculement vers
l'anarchie le scrutin se tiendra le 25
février 2023 à Sao Tomé l'opposition de
centre droit remporté les législatives
de dimanche annoncent de la commission
électorale qui n'a toutefois pas livré
la répartition des sièges qui
déterminera si la coalition de centre
gauche cédera ou non le pouvoir ce petit
archipel dans le Golfe de Guinée est
habitué à l'alternance il est considéré
comme un modèle de démocratie
parlementaire sur le continent
la mission de haut niveau des péchés au
Mali par la Cedeao son objectif étant de
dénouer la crise diplomatique avec la
Côte d'Ivoire la commission est composée
des présidents togolais Fornia Simba le
Ghanéen ananas
il doit arriver à Bamako jeudi dans la
matinée repartir en milieu d'après-midi
ce soir nous entamons une mini-série
consacrée à l'éducation alors que nous
sommes en pleine période de rentrée
scolaire nous avons décidé de nous
intéresser aux différents problèmes
rencontrés par les écoliers aujourd'hui
nous vous emmenons au Cameroun ou des
milliers d'enfants anglophones ont dû
fuir le conflit leurs écoles sont
régulièrement prises pour cible la
plupart d'entre eux se sont réfugiés en
zone francophone ils ont été confrontés
au défi du relogement de la
rescolarisation en plus d'avoir changé
d'environnement linguistique mais vous
allez voir un mélange la région du
Littoral un homme leur a tendu la main
reportage
ces jours de rentrée dans cette école
primaire de Milan région du Littoral au
Cameroun
l'hymne national du Cameroun chanté en
France et en anglais par ses adolescents
âgés de 4 à 13 ans ils sont tous des
déplacés qui ont fui les régions
anglophones du Cameroun ou Séville une
guerre huit clos sur fond de
revendications depuis octobre 2016
parmi eux simplissent 11 ans qui a
trouvé refuge ici avec ses parents et
ses quatre frères et sœurs encore
traumatisés par les atrocités qu'il a
vécu il vient de passer trois ans sans
aller à l'école des écoles ciblées par
les séparatistes anglophones
il y avait des coups de feu partout et
des armes de toutes sortes là-bas tout
ce qui se trouvait dans notre école a
été complètement brûlée lorsqu'il venait
dans nos villages pour combattre il
dormait dans nos écoles ici il n'y a pas
de guerre je suis heureux je voudrais
devenir ingénieur quand je serai grand
[Musique]
des élèves encadrés père des enseignants
comme Virginie elle-même déplacer un
terme exercer son métier lui permet
d'oublier les offres de la guerre même
si l'autre traumatisme reste présent
lorsque j'enseigne j'oublie le
traumatisme mais parfois si j'entends un
bruit je sursaute parce que l'expérience
des coups de feu est toujours présente
dans mon esprit des bons choix plus de
200 écoles ont été incendiés par les
séparatistes anglophones depuis 2016 et
un mot d'ordre de ville morte c'est
toujours en vigueur à l'origine de cette
rose scolarisation des déplacer interne
de la crise anglophone un bon samaritain
installé ici depuis 40 ans sa Majesté
Alexandre têtebon ancien gendarme à la
retraite j'ai de 80 ans lui-même
originaire de la région anglophone du
Sud-Ouest a créé cette école il y a 5
ans il accueille sur ses derniers
personnels une cinquantaine de familles
anglophones et se réjouit le frère une
seconde chance à ses adolescents c'est
satisfait d'avoir envie service à un
peuple à une nation ça 19e mais les
anciens eux aussi comme ils sont aussi
des déplacer ils font le sacrifice pour
encadrer nos enfants la guerre qui
déchire les régions anglophones du
nord-est du sud-ouest du Cameroun a déjà
fait près de 6000 morts et plus d'un
million de réfugiés et de déplacer
interne majorité les femmes et des
enfants c'est l'une des crises
humanitaires les plus négligées au monde
selon des ONG locales et internationales
voilà on poursuivra notre série demain
c'est la fin du journal de l'Afrique
restée avec nous l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]